hello everyone and welcome to what a
very well could be the best game that
was played in the 22nd European Team
Championship now the reason I say could
be and there is a title in the well note
title but there is a question mark in
the title is because of a debuffs game
but doubles game I'm gonna let you
decide which game is better and then
we're gonna decide together whether we
were gonna keep the question mark in the
title or we're just gonna remove it so
without further ado Alex a shear of
needs to no further introduction faces a
Swedish International Master Jonathan
Westerberg and it's best if we just dive
straight into it and if you haven't
checked checked it out already
the first thing you will see in the
description below is a link that will
take you to a Grand Master your hand
your Tori singing a beautiful song for
bobby fisher' and facial random so do
check it out if you still haven't and
now getting back to the game here of
opens with d4 with d5 knock'em c4 and
here c5 the Austrian defense something
very rarely seen in top-tier tournaments
out of elite players Chartres mamedyarov
is known to play it from time to time in
blitz and rapid not he did he never
played it in classical to my knowledge
once played it against Magnus Carlsen he
drew a game against Magnus in the st.
Louis rapid tournament but then again he
used it against each other I put in in
blitz game and then he lost but people
do play it
so Casey captures on b5 with Queen
captures on d5 and now Knight to f3
developing regarding the d4 pawn we've
see captures on d4 in here for example
in the cross and my media of game cousin
captured on d4 like we said that game
ended in a draw but that's not how a
shear of place he goes Knight to c3 just
developing with a tempo and now the
Queen has to move we have Queen to a5
just attacking well basically pinning
the attack piece and not a Knight
captures on d4 removing the point we
have Knight to f6 and now Bishop to e2
threatening some well not so nasty
discoveries as for the moment there
aren't any so ii 5 attacking the knight
and mount Nightbeat
b5 and here you have to be very careful
there is a very concrete threat here for
example if black is careless play
something like a Bishop e7 once the
castle just Knight d5 wins the game on
the spot as well the queen is under
attack and also there is the threat of
just Knight to c7 as both Knights are
now covering that square so even if you
capture here you still get 97 check and
you lose the Queen so yeah you already
have to be very careful now there are
some games that reach the disposition
Knights the a6 is a non move here which
covers the c7 square also Queen to b6 is
a non move just getting the Queen out of
the out of the nasty discoveries but
here we have Bishop to b4 by Westerberg
and it is a new move in the position so
already as a move eight we have a
completely new game not like as a move
to is it's not visual random anymore
and here like I said Bishop to b4 is a
new move but it's not a good move so
feel free to pause the video and try to
figure out why it's not a good move and
watch fear of played here while I give
you a couple of seconds for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on already punishing such an early move
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
it's a3 a3 the point being if you move
the bishop back and there is no good
square for the Bishop Knight to d5 again
will win the game for example wherever
you move the bishop you can go to d6 to
guard c7 because the knight the guards
dead square so here Bishop captures here
but now you no longer guard d6 so first
Knight to d6 check by shear of pink the
e7 and now Bishop captures on c3
attacking the Queen so here we have
Queen to d5 and it seems like black is
out of the woods next move he's gonna
trade Queens you don't really have a
choice otherwise you're gonna lose the
knight here so once again shiro finds a
brilliant attacking move which is Bishop
to b4 and now you just have to marvel at
this position it's just a beautiful
position because pretty much well not
pretty much nothing works in this
position just to give you an example if
you trade Queens here it doesn't help
you it doesn't alleviate the attack for
example Queen captures rook captures
now you're still threatening Knight
captures Bishop with a discover to check
which
we just win the win material so let's
say we try to move the King King e6 now
you get III the threat is Bishop to c4
check so where's the King gonna go for
example whatever you play knight c6 you
just get Bishop to c4 check and now
after the King moves you can go here the
knife covers the 5 so you have to go
back and now you get for example Knight
f5 check King to e8 and Knight captures
and g7 is mate the the bishop covers all
of these squares and the rook covers the
D file so just just short example of how
things can go very wrong if you trade
Queens here on the other hand if you try
and run away from all the nasty
discoveries let's say you try running
away immediately with King to e6 it
doesn't work white place Queen to c2 and
now again you're just threatening to
capture a piece there's a double attack
on the bishop now and also you're
covering the e4 square e for you just
efore followed by Bishop to c4 just wins
the game on the spot so here you could
go Bishop d7 but just efore and now
whatever you do let's say you try Queen
to c6 you you or for a queen trade but
Queen b3 check and now after the King
moves you're just gonna go Queen
captures on f7 which check King's gonna
move team to the 8th and now Bishop to
b5 this is this complete madness so
whatever you play here Queen to b6 you
could move the Queen now Queen captures
and g7 now everything is hanging the
rook is hanging the knight is hanging
it's just over the hunted this rope is
coming to d1 it's game over and after
Bishop to b4 you could try running away
in a different direction for example
King to d7 but then it is just Queen to
a4 with the check and now it's nice to
see 6 rogue d1 again you will get some
nasty discoveries after the Queen moves
or if you try Queen to c6 so you would
maybe trade Queens now you get Queen to
b3 again going for the f7 square and now
after black blocks once again now you
play Queen to g3 threat and g7 and also
rook to d1 so you cannot you cannot
defend against everything whatever you
play knight c6 rook to d1 is coming in
that's game over you either move the
Queen and face nasty discoveries or you
block with the knight but then you
III just attack the pin peace night see
to wit check it's a bit of a long line
but in the end it all works out for
white king e2 and now there are no moves
for black here you could try to give up
the Queen for some material here but
after all is said and done let's the
Queen e5 captures there's just nothing
to do you you're gonna bring your king
to f3 bring the bishop into the game
bring the rook into the game and it will
be an easy victory for white so here
they're just there is no easy move for
black and it's only moved 12 so really
amazing stuff so here Westerberg found a
way to continue he played Knight to c6
developing attacking the bishop and also
saying okay you grab this with a
discovery but how is your night getting
back into the game and this is exactly
what happened with Knight captures on c8
with check King to e6 and here we reach
the celebrated position of this game if
you follow any big website on Twitter
you probably saw this but if you don't
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the only winning move for white in
this position again while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who found it
congratulations you are you are a
natural born attacker it's just a
beautiful stuff you know McHale tall
stuff and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show its g3 yes that's the
move that's that's the only winning move
for white and now whatever you try it
simply doesn't work the thread is Bishop
to h3 if you allow Bishop to h3 check is
it's game over
so basically you have to ask can I
capture the rook is it is it is it a too
expensive rook maybe or do it do it
create Queens first but even trading
Queens doesn't help you still there is
no defense against Bishop to h3 just
whatever you play let's say capture this
for some reason all of the squares are
covered Bishop covers dark squares and
this Bishop covers the lights course so
the King has no King has no squares
you're gonna have to start giving up
material rook d6 check is an option
after King moves f3 it's just very
quickly the black king is getting
checkmated
so after g3 it's not an option at the
only way the only good way to prevent
Bishop to h3 is the play queen cap
percentage
and this is what what Jonathan played so
now Bishop h3 is impossible because the
king is still anyone but now the Queen
comes the d6 we have Queen to d6 check
King to f5 and now the again the only
good continuation Queen to b3 point
being that the King cannot go back if
you try to repeat moves with the King
going back then white just castles Queen
side and the next move you're just gonna
play Bishop to h3 there's not much you
can do about this and there already is a
rope here
you could try you could try playing
Queen captures on h2 but it doesn't work
just Queen to b3 with check and then not
a lot of squares are available to the
King you go King here 5 now you get
Knight to d6 check you push the King
further by further down the board the
King g6 now Queen to f7 check is coming
King g5 Bishop d2 check you run the King
down the board the King to g4 Queen g7
check King to h5 and then Queen to g5
will be mate so not possible to go back
with the King so II for black has to
fully commit here but with E 4 yes you
you block check but you also prevent
your queen from getting back into the
game so to get back into the game you
will at some point have to capture the
h2 pawn lose weight to move and then
somehow get her back in the game using
the H file so here she ro continues
Knight to d6 check King to g6 and now
again the only good attacking move Queen
to b5 threat is Queen to f5 check
followed by Bishop to d2 as the King
will find himself on h5 and it will be
over very quickly so Knight to e7
guarding DF v square and now Queen
captures on b7 is possible but she ro is
not you know just just gonna grab a pawn
so he shifts the night over to C for now
he wants Knights the e5 check again if
the King moves to h6 damn Bishop to d2
is deadly so Knight the c6 just going
back covering d5 square with the night
and only now Queen captures on b7 so now
the night is threatened with Knight
captures and b4 and now first night the
e5 with check covering the f7 square as
well
King to f5 and now calmly recapturing a
piece a capture son before there's no
rush
because Sharov is inviting Jonathon to
capture on e5 so to go for Luke to a5
check it's a forced mate here King to e6
Queen c6 check and now just run the King
the other way
rocky 5 check King v8 now go Queen d6
checking see it rook c5 check here check
you go back and the Queen to c7 will be
made so the King cannot capture the
knight on e5 so it's an excellent
outpost for the night with a 5 now
hoping to get the da rook into the game
but now queenside castle is very
interesting but also very complicated
I'm just gonna mention it as it does
look nice but you have to calculate
after Luke a c8 check King moves and now
Queen captures an h2 preventing Bishop
to h3 you have to find Queen B 5 and now
it's still a very complicated position
white is winning here
but she refines here finds a simple way
with without actually going for this
castling he plays Knight captures on f7
so what do you play here your rook on h8
is under attack you you can't just you
know give a give back material to get
back into the game because you are not
you are no longer up material I mean so
we have Luke H to f8 and now comes Luke
the c1 now introducing this rock into
the game as well we have h6 by black
hoping to hide the King over to h7 but
now Knight to d6 with check came to g6
and now rook the c7 going for root
captures on g7 we have Knights to h5 a
blocking the the g7 pawn and now another
excellent attacking move f3 just not
allowing the Queen to keep an eye on d4
pawn so now Queen captures on e4 with
check is the threat not allowing the
black king to escape so here even if you
capture the Queen just comes here and
checkmate is the black King not not
right away but very quickly for example
if you do this check King goes here h4
there are no moves you will you black
will have to give up the Queen so after
f3 we have King - h7 just hoping to
somehow hide that King
but Queen captures on e4 with check King
to g8 and now Queen to d5 just giving a
check
preparing to to pick up the night on h5
King h7 now Queen captures on h5 and now
after things settle down a bit it's
actually white who's up material White
has a bishop and the night for rook and
you know it might be playable for black
if black had any any moves but black
doesn't have any move so black plate
looked f6 trying to get the rock into
the game with tempo tonight is under
attack but now Knight to e4 attacking
the rook rook to g6 and now Queen to f5
now the rook is pinned here you cannot
move the King so here you don't have a
lot of good moves again you could
everything is too slow if you try to
bring the Queen inter game by Queen
captures on h2 just rook c6 you're not
gonna you're not gonna do too well there
there will be no way half to defend your
rook and on the other hand what else can
you play so rook the a6 was played
trying to defend this rook preventing
rook to c6 and also maybe hoping to
unpin but it's never a really a
realistic idea as this rook can always
go back to see it with check so here
Shiro just played h4 and it was in this
position unmoved 33 that Jonathan
Westerberg resigned the game as there is
no good defense against h5 here Shiro
will just attack the pin piece and
that's that's all there is
you could you could try something like
to unpin but we already said just rook
c8 checking has to go back again h5 just
when is the rook so it's it's pointless
so now after h4 western Berger designed
the game and a beautiful beautiful
victory for Alex a sheriff who is always
you know whether he wins or loses the
game is always interesting as you saw
here so I can't really I mean in my
opinion it's a it's a better game then
the not a better game than dubov played
but to me it's more aesthetically
pleasing than the one do both played as
do both had a mate in 13 it's a force
mate and you have to find it but here it
was just all of the these variations
were it was impossible
calculated all of them they were just
insane but they were you know unique
moves
Shiro found them and that g3 was just it
was just beautiful so if you agree you
know do share in the comments maybe
we're gonna take the question mark away
from the title if not maybe it will
remain there we'll see how it goes so
once again do check out the link in the
description below a song for bobby
fisher' by your hand yo Tory it's really
beautiful
do check it out I would like to thank
each and Parakh Jose lates on Montero
Ferrera
and Nicholas Reed for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to cover a few more games
from the European Team Championship as
we do have to check out the standings
and then we're gonna well have probably
probably have our vote on our next big
saga it's it's hard for me to lower the
D options as a lot of you suggested a
lot so I have to shut it down to maybe
four or five auctions but we are getting
there no worries so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day